i love ribs
welcome back to chasing our roots i'm
vanessa we are headed to the bay area to
try some amazing food and talk with some
great chefs so today we're gonna go hang
out with chef tony holland from brown
sugar kitchen in oakland
the food here is southern and soul food
it's not completely traditional i've
worked in a lot of different restaurants
cooks a lot of different cuisines so i
bring a little bit of my experience from
all over those places so i want to talk
to you about what we're making today so
we're going to make baby back ribs and
they have a pineapple brown sugar glaze
and we serve it with a pineapple salsa
so i wanted to play a little game with
you because i know how much you love
ribs so basically vanessa's on a desert
island and she can only have a rib or
the other thing i'm about to tell her
would you take a rib or jade your
girlfriend i'm gonna say ribs would you
take a rib or beyonce
beyonce would you take a rib or
chocolate i can't answer that there's
not one
higher than the other i love how this
got more hesitation than your girlfriend
this particular recipe has a caribbean
flavor profile with the jerk spice and
even the pineapple and the brown sugar i
am so ready to try these ribs we have
baby back ribs first thing we do is rub
it with a jerk spice give that a little
smell
good right definitely smell the cumin
and the curry in here why don't you
sprinkle it over on top and i'll kind of
rub it in it's got a savory and a sweet
flavor profile which i love would you
say that your spices are accessible for
other people to try the recipes are all
in the cookbook they're meant to be
shared how long are we putting it into
the smoker we're gonna put in for at
least three hours and then check it so
for folks at home who don't have a
smoker yeah what would you recommend
would be an alternative you could get a
pan like this put some wood chips down
that you soaked put the rib over the
wrap and then put it in the oven like
that
all right yeah let's go you know it's
been a lot of hard work to get here the
only neighborhood where you know i was
able to get a lease was this
neighborhood their argument was that i
had not owned a restaurant before but i
knew about the bay area people will go
and travel for good food so now we're
going to put the ribs on the griddle
this is a new concept for me usually i
just see them off the smoker and slice
it's really new you could do this on a
grill there's a nice quick
caramelization yep two to three minutes
on each side ribs are off the griddle
next thing we do is put on the uh brown
sugar pineapple glaze so this is just a
reduction of pineapple juice and brown
sugar okay yeah i top it with a little
pineapple salsa
enjoy
i remember
wow did they pass the test they're so
good thank you so we are here
getting the beauty shots and dasha is
doing such a good job
look at these ribs and dishes over here
picking on me she's over here letting
the ribs get cold
and being disrespectful
to the rib
quality control
this is a perfect medium for people who
don't like
dry rubbed ribs but also don't like wet
ribs right in the middle you're gonna
give me a hot rib i am because i love
you
i do see that stress smile
i think my generosity levels are pretty
high right now this was amazing thank
you
slaw everything like all the food that
we tried i really appreciate it
absolutely thank you so much
the ribs were amazing the combination of
the sweet and the spicy and the smoky
was so impressive to me what is really
cool is that all of her spices you can
get right at home and you can get the
same flavors the same ribs as you can
here in brown sugar kitchen
[Music]
[Music]